That was the third call you've disconnected today.
Listen, Robert. I don't know what's going on with you lately,...
...but if you don't start doing a better job real soon,...
...we're gonna have a real problem here.
I'm sorry. I know I haven't been doing my best.
Well, you need to figure something out.
I mean, I can't afford you making these many mistakes.
I understand that and I really do want to do a better job.
So, what's it gonna take?
I have some personal obligations that have been pulling my attention away from my work...
...and I think if I could just have a couple days to catch up,...
...I could come back to work much more focused.
All right, that sounds reasonable.
Why don't you put in for two personal days and I'll sign off on it?
That would really help. Thank you.
Sure, no problem.